back leading Britain's coronavirus
response after his personal battle with
the virus and only a day after his
fiancee gave birth the Prime Minister
faces mounting criticism of his
government's response to the outbreak
and questions over how to ease current
restrictions amid a backdrop of rising
deaths but now a glimmer of optimism in
Britain's battle with covert 19 I can
confirm today that for the first time we
are past the peak of this disease were
past the peak and we are on the downward
slope Britain may be over the worst but
it's still at risk for now the lockdown
will not be loosened we've come through
the peak or rather we've come under what
could have been a vast peak as though
we've been going through some huge
alpine tunnel and we can now see the
sunlight only the pasture ahead of us
and so it is vital that we do not now
lose control and run slap into a second
and even bigger mountain in the past 24
hours
pampers and flowers have been arriving
here to 10 Downing Street to welcome
Boyce Johnson's new baby closely
followed by scientific advisors of
Ministers clutching folders it is a
confusing juxtaposition echoing a wider
national confusion over how and when
this crisis will end the government's
also under mounting pressure to reach
its mass testing target by Friday at the
start of April the health secretary Matt
Hancock said he was determined to
deliver a hundred thousand tests per day
so determined he reportedly made a
hundred-pound charity bet he'd achieve
it in recent days mobile testing units
staffed by the army have been travelling
around the country as the government
races to meet its target smashing his
goal with an Air Force fly past is
captain Tom Moore he initially wanted to
raise just over a thousand dollars for
completing laps of his garden before his
hundredth birthday
the milestone having raised more than 37
million dollars for the National Health
Service the Prime Minister described
captain tom as a point of light for the
nation the government is now under
pressure to be a point of trust in
uncertain times neve barker al jazeera
london